orange
poisson
art
[Musique]
il suffit de trois mots simples les
homophones des polysémie et déjà sévi
temps vous des sensations radicalement
poser
certains se retrouvent déjà transporté
par les douceurs du petit déjeuner
matinal apporté au lit
d'autres laissent leur imagination
dériver vers des domaines qui leur
appartiennent
tandis que le reste d'entre vous peine
toujours à établir un lien rationnel
entre ces mots
aucune interprétation est identique car
chaque mode de pensée est unique
ce que ces mots vous évoque dépend votre
humeur de vos besoins actuels des
expériences passées que vous en avez
d'une multitude de facteurs dont vous
ignorer jusqu'à l'existence
et si au fond elle était là la clé
la clé de ce nouveau chapitre de votre
vie de cette page qui se tourne
la clé ses portes qui vous restent
hermétiquement fermées et si vous aviez
déjà entre vos mains
suite de votre parcours
pour bien comprendre de quoi il en
retourne je vais devoir remonter le
temps et faire appel un grand précurseur
de son domaine injustement le cauchemar
de vos cours de philo j'ai nommé sigmund
freud
la déception dans le public j'ai un père
la moitié de l'auditoire
mais rassurez vous c'est justement ce
qui nous attend pas
alors évidemment il n'y a pas de
consensus sur la désignation d'un
conscient de subvention de non conscient
lit sur les conclusions que frau tir de
ses recherches en la mais il ya tout de
même quelques leçons à tirer des siècles
de découverte en psychologie et en
neuroscience qui ont suivi ces travaux
que l'on parle de young kraft foods
brown epstein au ericsson pour ne citer
qu'eux
certitude pour certains
esprits pour d'autres dans tous les cas
je vous assure que ce que je m'apprête à
vous exposer ne peut que vous aider à
mieux appréhender les obstacles qui se
présentent à vous
heureusement pour vous un instant t il y
à de nombreux processus dont vous n'êtes
pas conscient
inconsciemment peut-être vous appréciez
le parfum entêtant de votre voisine de
devant et grincer des dents en entendant
votre voisin de droite se craquelle et
doit
maintenant que je vois certains d'entre
vous regardez leur voisin de droite avec
un air meurtrier c'est devenu conscient
je pense
et malgré toute votre bonne volonté il y
aura toujours des informations vous
manquerez du battement régulier de votre
coeur à la sirène inhabituel qui
retentit à l'extérieur
alors qu'on soit bien d'accord je parle
bien de s'étirer là resté avec moi en
fait pas comme tout à l'heure
avec un peu de chance si je vous ennuie
pas trop et que vous êtes bien concentré
sur le son de ma douce se voir on ne
remarque rien tous ces détails
ces informations pourtant où les
posséder
dans votre inconscient
tenez cette clé de l'appartement vous
vous acharnez à chercher en déplaçant
tous les meubles oui c'est très bien où
elle se trouve aux ions très bien vu
quand vous l'avez placé dans le frigo en
allant chercher le pot de nutella ce
moment là vous étiez probablement bien
plus absorbés par votre podcast sur la
déforestation et ses conséquences
dévastatrices sur les populations de
ramboutan note à part pas terrible
l'unité a dans ce cas là mais le fait
est là impossible de se rappeler où est
cette fichue clé
l'information vous parviendra plus tard
quand vous aurez déjà manqué votre
rendez vous retournez tout l'appartement
autre exemple
cet ami de longue date dont vous avez
oublié le prénom
deux heures plus tard le voilà qui
surgit soudainement dans votre esprit le
prénom pas l'ami après vous avoir
largement laissé le temps de vous
ridiculiser
ce qui est magique ici c'est que vous
n'étiez alors même pas conscients et
processus de réparation qui continuait
en arrière-plan
l'inconscient capture l'instant collecte
les signaux et tel un ordinateur lance
une recherche dans sa base de données
pour tenter d'y retrouver les
correspondances j'ai plus ou moins
rapide cela dépend du modèle
d'ordinateur
certaines informations resteront stockés
en attente d'être analysé lorsque l'on
pourrait appeler la mémoire vive
toutes seront directement analyser et
transmise à votre conscience
toujours est il que via ses bases de
données
l'inconscient transforme la réalité
objective
observable par tout le monde en une
réalité subjective qui vous est propre
ils donnent du relief à ce que vous
voyez santé entendez et comble même les
lacunes avec son propre vécu si
nécessaire
votre interprétation de la réalité nous
est unique
elle est le produit de votre éducation
aux croyances aux souvenirs vos
habitudes votre humeur du moment vos
interactions avec le monde chaque mot
vous prononcer ou écrivez chaque
sensation que vous expérimentez
absolument tout ce que vous vouliez est
le fruit d'une interprétation par votre
inconscient qui vous est unique
vos goûts vos couleurs uniques ou
préférent sentimentale unique aussi
opinion politique unique
personne ne dispose des mêmes ressources
lorsqu'il s'agit de prendre une décision
par conséquent il existe donc non pas
une seule réalité uniforme commune à
tout le monde mais une infinité de
réalité subjective
absolument
unique en un moment quelques-uns qui
suivent
non
revenons à ziigmund fraude pourquoi son
image est-elle si mauvaise dans votre
propre réalité subjective
de tête que vous jouiez au carpe en
cours de philo précisément et vous vous
en êtes tiré avec une heure de col en v
expérience
peut-être que le court était à 8 heures
du matin et
freud au lever du lit c'est douloureux
ont peut-être encore et est la voix
désagréable de votre professeur qui vous
a marqué
mais dans ce cas j'ai d'autres questions
pourquoi sa voix vous at elle marqué
pourrait continuer très longtemps dans
cette lancée et vous demandez pourquoi
vous n'aimez pas le marron pourquoi vous
enfilez toujours votre pull après votre
pantalon arbaud tubes en dessous en avez
vous seulement la moindre idée
non la théorie suivante
peut-être que cette voie vous était
désagréable car elle vous rappeler celle
tremblante de colère de votre père quand
à l'âge de 5 ans vous avez remplacé son
tube de dentifrice part du gel
hydroalcoolique
expérience traumatisante pour lui vous
aussi
arrêtez moi si je me trompe on partirait
donc
d'un tube de dentifrice
pour arriver à la détestation
inconditionnels de tout ce qui se réfère
à sigmund freud
j'avais un petit peu loin là vous
trouvez pas
vous l'avez compris une vaste majorité
de nos choix et habitudes et gouvernés
par notre inconscient
à chaque question vous avez peut-être
une réponse mais rarement vos
motivations
rarement le cheminement
il faut comprendre que le premier
réflexe de votre cerveau face à une
situation et de se demander pêche
survivre et de réagir en conséquence
et ce même si le danger n'est pas réel
selon que vous ayez en fouillant vous
des peurs des désirs des traumatismes
des secrets la décision finale transmise
à votre conscient qui vous apparaît
comme unique peut pourtant changer
totalement
l'idée de départ vous paraissez peut
être bonne mais l'expérience que vous en
avez vous retiendra toujours d'agir le
processus qui a mené à cette décision
s'il était à une époque salvateur est
aujourd'hui handicapant
théoriquement la faim devant be est
suffisamment traumatisante pour cause et
plus tard de l'île aux phobies sans pour
autant savoir d'où cela vient
dit comme ça ça peut paraître un petit
peu ridicule mais une phobie ça ne se
discute pas
ça ou donner naissance à une armée de
militants de la cause animale
une heure de film et votre vie et changé
à tout jamais
je sais pas vous mais moi je trouve ça
fascinant
fascinant et effrayant à la fois
peur du noir peur du vide
claustrophobie
lors de parler en public si je
m'écoutais je serai pas là en train de
vous endormir avec mes divagations
parfois ce qui nous retient peu gâché
notre vie et nous laisser passer à côté
de belles opportunités
alors comment en jambes et ses obstacles
qui vous retiennent comment lutter
contre le poison de l'habitude déjouer
ce piège que vous tendez à vous même
bonne nouvelle vous avez déjà fait la
moitié du chemin
soyez toujours conscients de l'impact de
votre parcours sur la réalité dans
laquelle vous vivez
alors que le nombre d'interprétations
possibles de la réalité objective
potentiellement très grand
votre vision du monde ne vous permets
d'en retenir qu'une seule
assurez vous que ces choix ne soit pas
toujours le résultat d'un même processus
défectueux
ce n'est qu'en identifiant les origines
profondes de ces choix on vous
connaissant mieux vous même que vous
pourrez les remettre en question
envisagez un autre chemin éventuellement
trouver ce nouveau souffle que vous
recherchez
pour autant garder à l'esprit que même
cette réalité objective que vous
analysez et parcellaire
pour preuve peu d'entre vous ont tant
fait remarquer que la pagination des
diapositives sur les décimales de pi que
je vous répète le mot merci en langue
des signes depuis que je suis arrivé en
boucle ou que mes lunettes du départ
sont bel et bien toujours dans ma poche
restez attentifs à ce qui se passe
autour de vous le monde est trop riche
pour être observé qu'avec les pieds
j'en suis intimement convaincu vous avez
en vous en chacun d'entre vous est fier
de votre réussite votre bonheur
et peut importe le sens et la force du
vent vous êtes les seuls à décider de le
suivre car si vous regardez bien depuis
tout ce temps le gouvernail est entre
vos mains
merci
[Applaudissements]